[MUSIC]
I think the impact of NLM globally is huge.
We know that its collections, especially
its online collections and resources
and tools are accessed by people all
over the country and all over the world.
It's there 24/7, 365, and it really makes
a difference when somebody's undergoing...
when they're at that crisis moment, they
don't have time to go to the physical
library and spend hours researching or
try to figure out where on the web has
valid health information. They know...
they can know this is a valid source--
it's been vetted properly--and it's
really there for them.
The impact is felt by everyone.
Researchers all over the world use our
products, and by products I mean our
databases, and so if we do something to
PubMed for example, we're gonna hear
about it from people that are not only
in the United States but all over the
world. And for a lot of these researchers,
PubMed is their first point of access to
the medical literature because it's free.
I would see it when I did reference just
answering reference questions from all
over the world--from physicians, community
organizations, the general public--
they come to us when they can go to their
own medical libraries in their country--
they come to us, which is rather a
compliment.
We have a friend in Malaysia, and about
five years ago his mother was diagnosed
with bladder cancer, and so he wrote
to us and he was just sort of asking
for our support and I said, "You know,
is there anything I can do to help you
get information about this, because you know,
I know a great source for that, MedlinePlus.
And he said that would be wonderful if
you could provide some information.
So I did a quick search and I came across
the MedlinePlus page on bladder cancer and
all the links to NCI bladder cancer
resources and other resources that were
out there for him, and I sent those to him
and about two or three months later
his mom had undergone some treatments
and he wrote back and he said,
"I really wanna thank you,
because you provided more information
to my family and I than her doctors did."
It is necessary to have one place that's
reliable, that's...that does not have any
commercial pressures to represent what
is the best known knowledge
in the field, and NLM offers that - worldwide.